Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je vais vous parler des arbres,
des forêts et de nous,
parce que nous sommes liés à elles, à eux.
J’aurais aimé vous y emmener.
J’ai bien un peu de lierre, espèce
forestière s’il en est, derrière moi,
mais je vais prendre
quelques images pour nous y transporter.
Ce que j’aime avec les arbres,
sauf rares exceptions,
c’est que tout le monde les aime.
Ce qui est plaisant, rassurant,
facilitant pour l’échange et le dialogue.
Sauf que parfois, ça paraît compliqué.
Il y a des débats,
des polémiques, des difficultés.
Ça tient au fait que tout le monde
n’aime pas les mêmes arbres,
n’aime pas les arbres de la même manière,
ni pour les mêmes raisons.
Et c’est là où ça se complique.
Parce que nos représentations,
nos perceptions des ligneux, des arbres,
et de leur société, les forêts,
sont variables entre
nos propres sociétés humaines
et surtout entre nos individualités.
Et effectivement, je pense qu’on a tous
en tête une forêt référence,
la forêt de l’enfance, la forêt des rêves,
mais il s’agit rarement de celle-ci
quand nous discutons
avec certaines personnes.
Première immersion,
petite expérience de pensée,
nous allons aller dans un espace.
Si je vous pose la question :
« Somme-nous dans une forêt ? »
A priori, vous allez tous me dire :
« Oui, évidemment, sinon c’est quoi ?
C’est une forêt,
c’est un espace avec des arbres. »
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
je suis d’accord avec vous.
Maintenant, si on change d’espace
et que je vous emmène là-bas,
est-ce que c’est toujours une forêt ?
Ou est-ce que c’est
une plantation résineuse ?
On pourrait appeler ça une pessière,
un peuplement d’épicéas.
Est-ce que c’est un écosystème
ou un habitat naturel ?
Est-ce que c’est une verrue
écologique, d’après certains ?
D’autres diront :
« C’est une belle usine à bois. »
Et d’autres encore diront :
« C’est une usine à bois moche. »
En fait, les avis sont divergents.
il ne m’appartient pas ici de trancher
cette question qui anime
les experts, les naturalistes,
les scientifiques, les forestiers.
Tous ces termes sont applicables
à ce peuplement, à cette forêt.
Simplement, ils dépendent
de notre perception,
différente entre chaque personne.
Ils sont chacun légitimes
mais ils sont divergents,
voire opposés.
Maintenant, je vous emmène
dans un autre espace,
que vous avez derrière moi.
Je vous repose la question :
« Sommes-nous dans une forêt ? »
Je ne parle que du premier plan,
pas de ce qu’il y a derrière.
Dans le premier plan,
sommes-nous dans une forêt ?
Les avis risquent de diverger un peu.
Et j’avais été marqué une fois parce
qu’une botaniste devant cette photo,
quelqu’un qui connait
les plantes, la végétation me dit :
« Ça ne peut pas être une forêt,
il n’y a pas d’arbres. »
« Ah bon ?
Et qu’est-ce que c’est qu’on a,
par plages, sur le devant de la photo,
si ce n’est des arbres ? »
Des petits arbres, des semis
comme on dirait en langage technique,
mais ce sont des arbres.
Finalement,
si j’ai des arbres, j’ai une forêt.
Une forêt en devenir, bien sûr,
ce n’est pas la forêt majestueuse
ou même la forêt qu’on avait juste avant.
Mais si on lui laisse
quelques dizaines d’années,
cette végétation deviendra
la forêt qu’on a en toile de fond.
Ce qui est important,
c’est que ces semis,
qu’on a parfois du mal
à imaginer comme des arbres,
vont devenir un jour des arbres,
normalement, ce sont des chênes.
Et les chênes vont devenir grands, matures
comme on peut le voir sur cette photo.
Dit autrement, tout grand chêne,
aussi grand soit-il,
a été un jour un gland.
Ce qui peut le rassurer
mais lui s’en fout.
Mais ça peut nous rassurer en disant :
« On arrivera toujours à quelque chose,
même si on est pas parti de grand-chose. »
Et ça illustre le fait que les arbres
sont des passerelles temporelles.
Ils nous permettent d’atteindre
une dimension qui nous échappe souvent,
celle du temps.
Ce sont même des machines
à remonter le temps.
Puisqu’en fait, quand l’arbre grandit,
il intègre à la fois dans
sa physionomie, sa croissance,
son environnement et son histoire.
Et son histoire est
un peu aussi notre histoire.
Paul Valéry disait :
« L’arbre, c’est le temps rendu visible. »
Effectivement, c’est quelque
chose qui est très intéressant.
Malgré ces termes variés, il existe
une définition officielle de la forêt.
Elle émane de la FAO,
Organisation des Nations Unies
pour l’agriculture et l’alimentation.
Elle est reprise par l’inventaire
forestier national, elle est officielle.
Je vais vous la donner, je vous avertis,
soyez attentifs car elle est technique.
Une forêt est un territoire
d’une superficie d’au moins 50 ares
avec des arbres atteignant une hauteur
de plus de cinq mètres à maturité in situ,
ayant un couvert boisé de plus de 10% et
une largeur moyenne d’au moins 20 mètres.
J’espère que c’est plus clair maintenant.
Vous avez officiellement
la définition de la forêt.
Essayons, pour voir
si vous avez bien compris,
de l’appliquer à cet espace
que j’ai derrière moi.
Je vous pose la question :
est-ce une forêt ou non ?
Nous pourrions passer quelques minutes,
à discuter des critères techniques
que j’ai évoqués précédemment
pour savoir si c’en est une ou pas.
Je pense qu’on n’arriverait pas
à se mettre d’accord.
Par contre, ce qui est intéressant,
c’est de prendre du recul sur cette photo
et si on prend ce recul,
toujours nécessaire,
c’est plus facile de voir
dans ce paysage une forêt
dont la partie qu’on a vu précédemment
n’est qu’un appendice, une bordure,
une extension qui est
d’ailleurs en pleine expansion.
Parce qu’effectivement, on s’aperçoit
ici que c’est quand même difficile
de donner une définition
partagée de la forêt.
Je reviens souvent
à ce que dit Francis Hallé
qui est un biologiste,
botaniste et dendrologue :
« La forêt, sa complexité rend
une définition simple impossible. »
Voilà, ça, c’est dit.
Elles ont un point commun,
par contre, c’est qu’elles bougent.
Si, les forêts bougent.
Vous me direz :
« Non, elles ne bougent pas,
pas plus qu’un arbre.
C’est ce qui nous différencie
nous, animaux, qui sommes mobiles,
voire très mobiles. »
Je vous affirme qu’elles bougent.
Il suffit de regarder un peu
les paysages autour de nous,
à un certain intervalle de temps,
pour s’apercevoir que la forêt bouge.
Regardez des photos aériennes anciennes,
actuelles de votre commune,
d’un territoire que vous connaissez.
Vous voyez que la forêt s’étend.
On dit que la forêt avance.
C’est donc qu’elle bouge.
Et j’en veux pour preuve
aujourd’hui au TEDxClermont
que si vous avez fait attention
depuis 14h que le TEDx a commencé,
le lierre qui est derrière moi
a largement progressé sur la scène.
C’est bien que la forêt bouge,
et qu’elle va recouvrir
la scène un de ces jours.
Partons, pas très loin, Le Puy de Dôme.
On connaît tous ici Clermont-Ferrand.
Voilà ce qu'il était au XIXᵉ siècle,
début du XXᵉ siècle.
Un espace complètement dénudé,
occupé par les pâtures, les cultures,
avec juste quelques arbres
isolés, taillés, émondés.
Pas de forêt, pas de bois.
C’était lié à une longue
phase de déboisement
lié à la mise en culture,
au besoin domestique, du chauffage,
des verreries, des forges,
toutes ces industries,
grandes consommatrices de bois.
Et au début de l’ère industrielle,
notre surface forestière était
à son minimum entre 10 et 15%
selon les régions de France.
Aujourd’hui, nous sommes à 31%
du territoire national métropolitain
couvert par la forêt,
17 millions d’hectares.
Ça représente un doublement
de la surface en moins de 200 ans,
ce qui est quand même assez rapide.
Le Puy de Dôme aujourd’hui,
on voit bien ces phénomènes,
il y a toujours quelques bosquets,
des espaces ouverts
mais on voit des grandes masses
de plantations d’épicéas.
On voit aussi des arbres qui colonisent
le flanc du Puy de Dôme.
C'est bien que la forêt avance.
On a ici l’attribut
fondamental des forêts,
celui qui nous en éloigne le plus,
c’est celui du temps.
Les forêts avancent avec
un atout qui est le temps
et le temps long que nous
n’avons généralement pas.
Et j’aime bien cette phrase
de Francis Hallé qui dit que :
« L’animal règne sur l’espace,
l’arbre sur le temps. »
Il en résulte que celui
qui domine le temps
est aussi le maître de celui
qui ne domine que l’espace.
Ces êtres vivants sans œil
et sans cerveau sont les maîtres.
Cela bouleverse notre philosophie.
Aussi, je vous invite à réfléchir
à notre positionnement
par rapport aux arbres, aux forêts
et à les considérer peut-être autrement
parce que ce sont des êtres,
des organismes vivants, pardon,
qui sont remarquables
et qui nous rendent bien des services.
Mais ce n’est pas parce
qu’ils ont le temps long,
qu’ils nous paraissent immuables,
qu’ils ne subissent pas
des perturbations importantes,
comme ici lors de la tempête
de 1999 dans le Puy de Dôme.
Et un autre événement cataclysmique
que vous avez probablement en tête,
ce sont les incendies de forêt
qui ont ravagé 62 000 hectares
en France cette année,
notamment cet été.
Les arbres résistent
rarement à l’incendie.
Par contre, la forêt, si on la
considère comme l’écosystème,
ce qu’il y a au dessus et
en dessous, elle est toujours là.
Elle est même bien vivante.
Certes, elle est rajeunie,
elle a changé de physionomie
mais elle est dynamique,
elle est prête à repousser,
prête à croître avec de nouveaux arbres
avec même de nouvelles essences.
Elle est là.
Et cette capacité de résilience
est importante.
C’est le fait de revenir
à un état d’équilibre
qui est rarement
celui qu’elle avait avant.
Ce n'est pas un retour à l'état antérieur.
Et cette capacité de résilience
est rassurante pour elle
mais aussi pour nous qui en dépendons.
Un autre exemple intéressant,
c’est la ville de Prypiat,
que peut-être peu connaisse.
C’est une ville ukrainienne à 3 km
de la centrale nucléaire de Tchernobyl.
Là, on situe un peu mieux.
Et cette ville jeune, car elle a été créée
en 1970 pour accueillir les employés,
finalement, est déjà un fantôme.
Car évidemment, en 1986,
après l’accident nucléaire,
elle a été vidée de ses occupants
et elle est restée en libre évolution.
On s’aperçoit aujourd’hui, 36 ans après,
que la forêt a regagné
toute seule, sans nous,
les espaces qui lui avaient été enlevés.
Et elle a regagné avec les cortèges
de plantes, d’animaux, de champignons,
de bactéries, pas tous mais une partie.
Finalement, si cette forêt,
on l’a laissait pousser sans la déranger,
peut-être qu’elle arriverait à ce stade.
Ce qu’on appelle des forêts matures.
Ici, c’est dans une réserve naturelle
en Slovaquie centrale, à Dobroc,
et on a cette forêt
qui est en très bonne santé
grâce notamment à tout le bois mort.
Vous voyez sur la photographie,
tout ce bois mort qui est source de vie
pour l’écosystèmes forestier.
Et cette source de vie permet
à la forêt sa fonctionnalité,
ça lui permet de résister,
d’être résilient, de se regénérer
et au final, de se perpétuer.
Et ça, c'est important.
Les arbres et les forêts ont
le temps long avec eux.
Moi je ne l’ai pas, mon temps est compté
il va me falloir conclure
mon intervention.
Surtout ne rien conclure sur
la question des arbres, des forêts
mais plutôt trouver matière à réflexion,
trouver aussi des pensées
positives à emporter
en se disant que la plupart des forêts,
je n’en fais pas une généralité absolue,
mais la plupart des forêts sont,
finalement, dynamiques, résilientes
En plus, elles sont généreuses.
Mais il y a des menaces,
des risques qui pèsent sur elles.
Je ne suis pas angélique
en disant tout va bien.
Par contre, ce qui est sûr, c’est que
les enjeux, les choix qu’on doit faire
actuellement et dans le futur,
ce sont des choix pour nos sociétés,
pour l’humanité, pas pour les forêts.
Ça veut pas dire qu’il faut les oublier.
Simplement, quoi qu’il se passe,
l’état dans lequel elles seront
ou la manière dont elles y arriveront,
elles ont la capacité intrinsèque
de perdurer après nous, sans nous.
Ça, c’est rassurant pour elles.
C’est rassurant pour nous aussi.
Cette illustration que j’aime beaucoup
parce qu’elle schématise
l’ensemble des biens
et services que la forêt,
et les arbres qui la compose,
rendent à nos sociétés humaines.
Il y a classiquement cinq blocs.
Il y a l’aspect biodiversité et écologie
et l’aspect production de bois,
bien sûr, de services.
Il y a l'aspect social, le côté récréatif,
il y a l'aspect captation du carbone.
Et ça, c’est un enjeu
de plus en plus important
contre les changements climatiques.
Et un cinquième enjeu qui est
celui de la protection contre l’érosion.
C’est quelque chose que j’ai entendu
dans les zones de montagne.
Finalement, les forêts nous protègent.
Nous nous devons
de les protéger à notre tour.
C’est un juste retour des choses.
Cette gestion forestière
multifonctionnelle
comme illustrée derrière,
c’est le socle de la politique
forestière française.
Celle qui est mise en œuvre
par les forestières et les forestiers,
au quotidien,
qui gèrent et veillent les forêts.
Nos métiers sont riches,
passionnants mais complexes
car la forêt est un écosystème,
un milieu complexe
et nous ne savons pas tout,
loin s’en faut.
De plus, les effets du changement
climatique déjà perceptibles,
viennent compliquer la donne,
bouleverser ce que l’on savait,
ce que l’on pensait savoir
et ce qu’on était en train d’en faire.
Et cela nous amène à devoir
faire des choix différents.
L’avantage est que
nous avons toujours le choix.
Ça, c’est important.
Plusieurs choix possibles,
une perturbation en forêt, un incendie.
Je peux avoir une action dynamique,
je reboise avec telle ou telle essence.
Je peux avoir une patience active.
Je laisse faire la nature.
Qu’apporte t-elle à l’écosystème ?
Que met-elle comme semis ?
Je regarde si ça me convient
et si je complète
par quelques plantations.
Et on peut aussi décider
d’avoir une inaction réfléchie,
laisser la nature cicatriser le milieu
et  se dire qu’on verra dans quelques
temps ce qu’on peut en faire pour nous.
Tous ces choix sont légitimes, pertinents
mais ça dépend beaucoup
des contextes et des acteurs.
Ça dépend notamment
du choix du propriétaire.
Finalement, pour rejoindre
le thème du TEDx,
après une perturbation en forêt,
est-ce qu’il faut replanter ?
Est-ce qu’il faut régénérer ?
Est-ce qu’il faut recréer ?
Est-ce qu’il faut revitaliser les forêts ?
Tous ces choix restent possibles.
Et cette question
éminemment importante
pour les forêts, pour nous,
ne peut et ne doit surtout pas être
résolue de manière générale et définitive.
On ne peut pas, en tant que professionnel,
donner une réponse ferme et définitive.
C’est plus complexe que ça.
Mais la solution existe
et nous sommes là,
forestiers, forestières,
pour expliquer, éclairer,
proposer ces choix
et les accompagner auprès de vous,
de la société, de nous tous.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)